bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat tout l'été je vous
propose de voir ou de revoir les temps
fort de la dernière session
parlementaire avec aujourd'hui un focus
sur le projet de loi Macron projet de
loi croissance activité égalité des
chances économiques qui a été
définitivement adopté au début de l'été
le 10 juillet dernier mais qui avait
donné lieu auparavant à des débats
nourris notamment en première lecture
que cela soit au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui je vous propose de
revoir l'un des temps fort de la
première lecture au Sénat ce moment où
les sénateurs ont discuté et bien de
l'ouverture des commerces le dimanche
vous savez c'est l'une des mesures
phares de ce texte le gouvernement qui a
fait passer le nombre d'ouverture
dominical des commerces de 5 à 12 mais
les sénateurs à l'époque voulaient aller
encore plus loin notamment dans les
zones touristiques également les at
voulait qu'en cas où il n'y avait pas
d'accord collectif dans l'entreprise et
bien on puisse passer par un référendum
pour travailler le dimanche tout de
suite donc retour à ce débat au Sénat
madame David vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président en effet nous
abordons aujourd'hui comme vous venez de
le dire le titre 3 chapitre 1er de ce
projet de loi qui légifère sur les
exceptions au repos dominical et en
soirée depuis 1906 et la loi sarien loi
républicaine humaniste et laïque sur le
repos dominical de nombreuses
modifications ont été apportées à ce
droit souvent de manière peu ordonné du
reste jusqu'à la loi de 2009 dite loi
maillé dont chacune et chacun ici a
connaissance ainsi et comme le soulligne
notre rapporteur à l'heure actuelle
cohabit des dérogations permanentes qui
sont de droit des dérogations
conventionnel sur la base d'un accord
d'entreprise et des dérogations
temporaires accordées par le préfet ou
le maire néanmoins les sénatrices et
sénateurs communistes affirment que
l'objectif poursuivi alors reste
d'actualité garantir aux salariés et aux
travailleurs et travailleuses le droit
au repos et à la famille comme avec
comme enjeu de faire du dimanche non pas
en tant que tel un jour de repos mais
bien la garantie à toutes et tous nos
concitoyens le droit de bénéficier d'un
même jour chôumé par semaine c'est pour
nous et pour une grande majorité des
salariés qui reste opposé au travail du
dimanche la garantie d'un temps commun
pour soi pour ses proches pour la vie
sociale culturelle sportive ce droit au
repos dominical est d'ailleurs un des
marqueurs de notre société le dimanche
étant devenu au fil du 20e siècle la
journée consacrée à la famille à
l'exercice des pratiques culturelles
sportives touristiques et cultuelles
notre collègue Patricia chilinger
n'hésitez pas à dire en 2012 lors du
débat ici même sur dans notre
proposition de loi sur le travail
dominical adopté par notre Haute
Assemblée je la cite que le travail du
dimanche conduit à un délitement des
liens humains et à une perte des valeurs
au seul bénéfice de la recherche du
profit qui ne représente en aucune façon
une solution pour relancer la
consommation et qui ne fait que
fragiliser les petits commerces de
proximité au profit des grandes
surfaces pour autant le principe du
repos dominical a toujours été assorti
de dérogation je le disais en
introduction qui se justifie soit par la
nécessité d'assurer la continuité de nos
services publics soit par les
contraintes techniques de certains
secteurs industriels qui doivent
fonctionner en continu ou encore pour
répondre aux besoins de la clientèle tel
qui répondent certains de nos commerces
de proximité à ce sujet je précise bien
qu'il n'a jamais été question pour nous
de revenir sur ces dérogations puisque
celles-ci sont strictement encadrées par
le Code du travail justement parce
qu'elles pent atteinte à la vie des
salariés à leur famille aussi et à leur
santé or cet encadrement permet de moins
en moins au salariés de bénéficier de
contrepartie en rapport avec leurs
astreintes de plus la loi malier à
laquelle je faisais référence en
introduction a introduit face à ces
dérogations des inégalités en fonction
de la zone dans laquelle travaillent les
salariés concernés qui de fait n'ont pas
les mêmes droits en fonction que vous
travaillez en zone touristique ou en
plus vos droits sont différents ainsi
que vos compensations en zone
touristtique les salariés ne peuvent
prétendre ni au volontariat ni aux
contreparties financières du reste même
au sein d'une zone puce les salariés
sont soumis à des inégalités de
traitement car si la loi maillé a prévu
des contreparties légales celles-ci
peuvent être inférieur à la loi en cas
d'accord collectif par nos amendements
sur ce chapitre nous allons vous
proposer de remédier à cette inégalité
sans pour autant renoncer aux valeurs
qui nous sont chères à savoir maintenir
le droit au repos dominical ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre ministre même si
vous prétendez que justement votre
proposition revient sur les inégalités
issues de la loi maillet nous ne pouvons
vous suivre car il n'en reste pas moins
vrai que sur le fond les arguments
énoncés en 2012 restent criant de vérité
non seulement nous souhaitons assurer
une protection équivalente aux salariés
employés dans ces deux catégories
d'établissement comme le préconise
d'ailleurs la commission d'experts pour
l'application des conventions et
recommandations de l'Organisation
internationale du travail mais nous nous
voulons garantir un véritable droit au
repos dominical tel que voulu par le
législateur à son origine afin de
préserver tant la santé et la vie
quotidienne des salariés que les valeurs
qui nous sont chères ici à gauche de
l'hémicycle merci Madame David la parole
est à Monsieur Vatin
oui nous abordons avec cet article le
volet de ce texte consacré à
l'élargissement du travail du dimanche
vous le savez nous sommes opposés à ces
dispositions car nous considérons que le
travail du dimanche doit demeurer une
exception et nous ne souhaitons pas que
plus de salariés travaillent le dimanche
je rappelle tout de même qu'ils étaient
plus de 6 millions et demi à le faire en
2011 selon les chiffres de la daress
rappelons aussi que le travail du
dimanche est une mesure dérogatoire au
code du travail il y a donc selon nous
une certaine hypocrisie affirmer que le
travail dominical devrait demeurer une
exception et dans le même temps à
soutenir la possibilité de faire
travailler près d'un/art des dimanches
de l'année un dimanche par mois et même
tous les dimanches de l'année une partie
de la soirée pour les futures zones
d'intérêt touristique le repos dominical
est un acquis social essentiel un
vecteur de cohésion sociale qui ne peut
être mis sur le même plan qu'un
hypothétique droit à consommer je dis
hypothétique car il n'chappé à personne
que le pouvoir d'achat du nombre de de
nombre de nos con citoyen est en berne
et y compris ceux qui acceptent de
travailler le dimanche pour améliorer de
très bas salaire alors ce pouvoir
d'achat nous le savons tous ne deviendra
pas extensible par la seule ouverture
des commerces le dimanche on invoque
pour justifier cette banalisation du
travail du dimanche le fait que les
consommateurs seraient en quelque sorte
Avid de faire les magasins le dimanche
un lieu de promenade les touristes
fortunés étrangers seraient empêchés
d'arpenter le dimanche les grands
magasins du boulevard Osman les
boutiques du boulevard Saint-Germain ou
des Champs-Élysées mais on parle peu des
salariés qui se verront privés du loisir
de bénéficier de leur repos dominical et
les rapports des deux commissions
spéciales se sont très peu penchés en
réalité sur les conséquences de ces
dispositions en terme d'organisation
sociale et familiale or la note de 2011
de la DARES sur le travail du dimanche
le soulligne je le cite travailler le
dimanche va presque toujours de paire
avec le travail du samedi et souvent
avec des horaires tardifs ou variables
d'une semaine à l'autre fin de citation
les femmes très présentes dans le
secteur du commerce de détail ù le temps
partiel subi est très développé seront
donc particulièrement concerné nous
savons que les familles monoparentales
de plus en plus nombreux c'est un fait
de société sont aussi majoritairement
aujourd'hui assumé par des femmes qui se
trouveront en difficulté pour faire
garder leurs enfants alors vous allez me
dire monsieur le ministre que votre
texte prévoit désormais que l'accord
fixe les contreparties mises en œuvre
par l'employeur pour compenser les
charge induite par la garde des enfants
pour les salariés privés du repos
dominical encore faudra-t-il que ces
salariés réussissent à trouver un mode
de garde ce jour-là une gajure parfois
comp tenu du manque de place de garde en
France et singulièrement en île- de
France je ne partage pas non plus
l'optimisme de Madame Anne Perro la
présidente de la commission d'étude des
effets la loi pour la croissance et
l'activité pour qui je cite son audition
dans la commission spéciale du Sénat on
peut donc imaginer que cette mesure
contrairement à ce qu'on a beaucoup
entendu ici et là puisse être favorable
travail féminin et aux personnes qui
n'ont qu'un emploi temps partiel
celui-ci pouvant être complété selon fin
de citation le travail du dimanche comme
remède à la précarité du travail des
femmes admettez mes chers collègues que
c'est tout de même un comble au travail
du dimanche nous préférons nous
l'égalité salariale et la fin du temps
partiel imposé vous le voyez nous ne
partageons pas votre vision monsieur le
ministre idéalisé de ce texte en terme
de progrès texte qui revient au final en
réalité à proposer pour une catégorie de
salarié employés dans un secteur déjà
mal rémunéré peu considéré le travail du
dimanche comme seul horizon de
progression de leur pouvoir d'achat
merci monsieur lein monsieur de cessard
vous m'z demander la
parole bonjour monsieur le Président
chers collègues monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre 3e semaine
d'ailleurs on aurait pu penser que c'est
le ministre du Travail qui là c'est pas
que je pas de plaisir avec vous monsieur
le ministre de l'économie mais enfin on
voit très bien que la question de qui se
discute sur le travail le dimanche c'est
le Ministre de l'économie et c'est pas
le ministre du Travail bon voilà donc ça
dire qu'on a oublié
une un aspect important de ce problème
alors avec les articles 71 à 82 le
projet de loi propose de réformer les
règles concernant le travail dominical
et
nocturne concernant le travail dominical
le droit actuel comprend trois
dispositions qui permettent déjà de
déroger à la règle d' rau le dimanche
tout d'abord les dérogations permanentes
prévu à l'article L r 31325 du Code de
travail pour les hôtels les hôpitaux les
entreprises de transport cela paraît
naturel
ensuite les dérogations conventionnelles
qui nécessitent un accord collectif déjà
avec majoration de rémunération de moins
50 % cela paraît naturel enfin les
dérocations accordées par voie
administrative soit dans les cas des
Dimanches du maire soit dans le cas des
puces périmètre d'usage de consommation
exceptionnelle sur Paris Lille et
Marseille ou soit par autorisation
préfectoire
le
gouvernement souhaite créer trois
nouvelles zones dans le dans lesquelles
le travail dominical serait permis sous
conditions les zones touristiques
internationales sur Paris daauville Cann
et Nice bénéficiant d'un afflux de
touristes étrangers les zones
commerciales remplaçant les puces de la
loi maillé et permettant leur
généralisation sur le
territoire les zones touristiques
regroupant les communes d'intérêt
touristique ou thermal et les zones
touristiques d'inffluence exceptionnelle
ou d'animation culturelle et
permanente il prévoit également
d'augmenter le nombre de dimanches du
maire de 5 à 12 de fixer la durée des
autorisations d'ouverture administrative
à 3 ans pourquoi nous y reviendrons et
d'autoriser une ouverture toute la
journée des commerces dans l'emprise des
grandes gares en un mot ce qui nous est
proposé ici c'est une diffusion du
travail dominical sur tout le territoire
c'est la généralisation du travail
dominical dans quel but et je l'avais
abordé en début de début de mon
intervention l'emploi dites-vous on nous
promet des milliers d'emplois créés une
libération des énergies et plus de
souplesse donné aux entreprises ça c'est
un mot qui revient souvent et à droite
et à gauche comme d'habitude mais pour
qu'il y ait de l'emploi il faut qu'il y
ait de la consommation des gens qui
achètent et qui font vivre les
entreprises dans les cadres de zones
touristiqu international je vous
l'accorde il peut y avoir quelques
touristes chinois qui ont envie de
d'acheter le dimanche ou quelques
touristes russes qui veulent acheter à
Nice le dimanche peut-être peut-être
hein bon peut-être mais pour le reste
pour les commerces destinés aux
consommateurs français qui seront
désormais ouverts les personnes qui
achèteront un bien le dimanche ne
l'achèteront plus en semaine il s'agit
simplement d'un autre rythme de
consommation les écologistes sont pour
la réduction du temps de travail
travailler moins c'est accorderer plus
de temps à ses proches à sa famille et à
s'occuper de l'éducation de ses enfants
à s'instruire à aider les autres
généraliser le travail du dimanche c'est
au contraire briser ses rythmes de vie
commun qui fond de notre société quand
les travailleurs récupéreront les jours
travaillés le dimanche à travers toute
la semaine où seront où sera la vie
commune où seront les temps d'échange et
de partage dans la famille Vous vous
plaignez qu'il y a un manque d'éducation
parfois dans certaines familles mais si
vous demandez aux gens de venir
travailler le dimanche alors que les
enfants sont en vacances le dimanche
quand est-ce qu'ils auront le contact
avec leurs enfants il faut être quand
même logique vous pouvez pas toujours
réclamer une chose et son contraire le
lendemain pour le travail nocturne c'est
la même logique qui à l'œuvre
aujourd'hui le travail nocturne commence
à 21h vous nous proposez monsieur le
ministre de le repousser à minuit dans
les zones internationales c'est encore
3h de moins pour soi sa famille et ses
an amis à noter également que le travail
de nuit comporte des risques réels et
avérés sur la santé des travailleurs
cela a déjà été dit trouble digestif et
déséquilibre nutritionnel désadaptation
et isolement social risque
cardio-vasculaire accru probabilité plus
élevée de cancer notamment du sein
écolorectal et sur chez femme enceinte
un risque plus élevé de prématurité et
fausse
couche ce n'est pas moi qui l'ai inventé
c'est sur le site du ministère du
Travail un site d'ailleurs il est pas là
c'est pas sur le site du ministère de
l'Économie d'accord hein inciter les
salariés à se mettre en danger pour leur
travail ne constitue pas à nos yeux une
réponse satisfaisante au problème du
chômage en conclusion dédier sa vie à la
consommation briser les rythmes partager
de travaill et de repos parfois au
mépris de la santé des travailleurs
voilà ce que nous propose ce projet de
loi dans ce chapitre et voilà pourquoi
les écollgiste vous
proposons la suppression de la plupart
des articles qui composent cet article
je vous remercie et la parole est à
madame
linman monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues beaucoup
d'arguments ont déjà été donné par mes
collègues du groupe communiste ou mon
collègue écologiste euh qui plaide dans
des faveur de l'élargissement du travail
du dimanche c'est une vieille une
vieille bataille de la gauche une
vieille bataille du monde du travail de
ne pas voir l'élargissement de ce
travail du dimanche et donc je ne
reprendrai pas en détail les arguments
mais j'en appelle à la fidélité et aux
engagements que nous avons pris devant
les Français il se trouve que lorsque
Monsieur Sarkozi a voulu élargir le nom
de dimanche travaillés le Parti
socialiste auquel j'appartiens
avait fait un tracte
particulièrement
conséquent expliquant je le cite cette
décision sera inefficace sur le plan
économique dangereuse pour les salariés
et néfaste pour la vie sociale les
arguments étaient clairs un effet nul
sur la croissance une fausse liberté
pour les salariés je ne vais pas
détailler une décision destructrice
d'emploi un modèle de société
inacceptable
pour une société plus juste refusons la
généralisation et l'élargissement du
travail du dimanche puis viennent les
élections de
2012 le candidat François Hollande
explique lorsqu'il est interrogé sur ce
sujet qu'en aucune façon il ne veut
élargir le travail du dimanche et il
reprend l'argumentaire historique de la
gauche et du Parti socialiste et il se
trouve que le au mois d'avril le 11
avril madame au monsieur Jean-Christophe
cambadellis Monsieur Manuel Vals et
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
membres du Parti socialiste ont déposé
un texte qui porte le beau nom de
renouveau
socialiste dans ce texte qu'est-il écrit
le repos
dominical nous sommes opposés à une
nouvelle extension du travail du
dimanche c'est d'abord un choix de
société la consommation ne peut-être
l'alpha et l'oméga de de nos vies le
dimanche doit d'abord être un moment du
vivre ensemble c'est une question de
protection des salariés les plus
fragiles pour lesquels la liberté de
choix n'existe pas réellement de
protection de petits commerces qui
restent souvent les dernières activités
présentes dans les quartiers en
difficultés et dans les zones rurales
désertifiées je le dis bien ce texte dit
nous sommes opposé à une nouvelle
extension du travail du dimanche il ne
vous a pas échappé chers collègues que
la loi n'est pas votée que donc la la
situation actuelle c'est le nombre de
dimanchees défini par l'actuelle loi et
pas celle que nous sommes en train
d'examiner alors en cohérence avec ces
déclarations puisque monsieur Vals le
Premier ministre bon nombre de
gouvernements prennent l'engagement de
ne pas faire une nouvelle extension par
rapport à la situation ex actuelle je
vous interroge monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie on aurait aimé avoir aussi le
ministre du Travail êtes-vous prêt à
supprimer les articles qui élargissent
le nombre de de dimanche travailler ce
serait en cohérence avec ce qui était
signé par Monsieur Vals madame Oubri et
bien d'autres en tout cas je pense que
c'est attendu par nos concitoyens par
les hommes et les femmes de gauche et
qu'effectivement ce serait un des
leviers d'un renouveau
socialiste merci Madame
LB nous passons à deux amendements
discussion commune
le numéro 65 madame la Présidente
assassie vous avez la parole oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement demande vous l'aurez compris
la suppression donc de l'article 71 du
texte nous avons donc une opposition de
de principe avec cet article et bien
évidemment avec ceux qui le le suivent
votre position monsieur le ministre
consiste en fait à à à dire que le droit
du travail tel qu'il a été modifié par
les différents textes de la droite
notamment place les salariés qui
travaillent le dimanche dans les
commerces dans des situations inégales
vous avez rappelé que trois situations
existent actuellement la première pour
les salariés qui travaillent dans les
établissements qui bénéficient d'une
dérogation au repos dominical ou dans
une commune ou zone touristique il n'y a
pas d'obligation légale de contrepartie
deè 2è élément pour les salariés qui
travaillent dans des établissements
bénéficiant d'une dérogation temporaire
accordé par le préfet dans les puces ou
pour les dérogations au titre du
préjudice au public et de l'atteinte au
fonctionnement normal de l'établissement
la loi a fixé un minimum d'un doublement
de la rémunération et d'un repos
compensateur en l'absence d'un accord
collectif meilleur enfin pour les
salariés qui travaillent l'un des cinq
dimanches du maire la loi fixe le
doublement de la rémunération et le
repos de compensateur en contrepartie
vous auriez pu améliorer la situation
existante tenter encadrer le travail
dominical en limitant les dérogations
existantes et en établissant les
contreparties dans la loi à savoir une
rémunération au moins égale au double de
la rémunération normalement du pour une
durée équivalente à moins qu'un accord
collectif ne prévoit des dispositions
plus favorables mais vous avez donc
préféré généraliser les dérogations au
repos dominical en renvoyant uniquement
aux accords collectifs sans contrepartie
minimale je tiens quand même à vous
rappeler que dans cette et cela a
été dit je peux le voir même rappeler
toute la gauche sénatoriale donc avait
approuvé notre proposition de loi visant
à garantir le droit au repos dominical
qui prévoyait justement la première
option et donc pour cette raison nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
libéralisation du travail du dimanche
madame la Présidente le 780 n'est pas
soutenu donc quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement de
suppression madame
deoche alors sur cette sur cet
amendement la Commission a mis un avis
défavorable puisque vous estimez que
l'article 71 vise à étendre les
exceptions au repos dominical et en
soirée ce qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité puisque'au contraire l'article
introduit un plafond de durée à 3 ans
pour les dérogations individuelles au
rep dominical accordé par le préfet donc
il y aura au contraire tous les 3 ans
une une remise remise à niveau et et est
ce qui est plutôt une amélioration par
rapport à l'existant et qui est plutôt
dans le sens d'une d'un meilleur
contrôle du de ces dérogation et donc
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission merci Madame la rapporteur
monsieur le ministre quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement
oui monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs en effet nous
reviendrons dans le cadre de la
discussion article par article et
j'aurai l'occasion de répondre à chacune
et chacun sur les points qui ont été
soulevés sur l'ensemble de ce texte mais
sur l'article 71 et l'amendement que
vous proposez il s'agit plutôt en effet
là d'une mesure extrêmement ponctuelle
ces autorisations préfectorales quelles
sont-elles sont des autorisations
ponctuelles qui sont accordées par le
préfet alors elles peuvent l'être par
exemple quand un magasin demande de
pouvoir ouvrir le dimanche pour fin
d'inventaire quand par exemple à la
périphérie d'une zone un magasin se
trouverait en situation d'être laésé de
pouvoir
ouvrir alors même qu'il est en frontière
de de puce ou autre et donc cet article
71 il vise à organiser justement ces
autorisations préfectorales et leur
donner un plafond de 3 années alors même
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas de limite de
plafond donc si on si on supprimait
comme vous le demandez cet article 71
les autorisations préfectorales
continueraient à exister comme elles
existent aujourd'hui simplement sans
limitation de durée donc je pense que ça
n'est d'ailleurs pas l'objectif que vous
recherchez je comprends le et vous
l'avez vous l'avez très bien rappelé he
l'hostilité qui est la vôtre à la
démarche d'ensemble qui est ici conduite
on aura l'occasion d'y venir point par
point mais c'est un dispositif ici qui
est plutôt protecteur et qui vise à
encadrer donc l'autorisation
préfectorale l'article qui plusé précise
les modalités de consultation des
parties intéressées par le préfet et
donc je pense que la demande de
suppression que vous faites n'est même
pas conforme à l'esprit que vous porter
en opposition à ce texte donc j'aurais
plutôt une demande de retrait sinon pour
les raisons que je viens v sinon non
mais c'est c'est c'est exact puisque là
vraiment il s'agit d'un article qui
vient préciser de l'existant qui ne
l'étend pas euh qui vient préciser les
modalités de consultation qui le limite
dans le temps et donc j'aurai une
demande euh de retrait sinon j'aurais
donc un avis défavoraablees pour les
raisons expliquées merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur bquet vous m'avez
demandé la parole pour explication de
vote
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre donc monsieur le ministre
vous venez de d'apporter quelques
éléments de réponse à la question que
j'allais vous poser concernant les
urgences qui seront livrées à
l'appréciation de Monsieur le Préfet
vous en avez cité deux mais qui nous
laissent tout à fait sceptique en
l'occurrence donc nous reconnaissons
bien le caractère indispensable des
dérogations pour assurer la continuité
des missions de service public ou de
certaines activités industrielles pour
de petits commerces alimentaires mais
nous ne pensons pas que le fait d'aller
acheter du papier peint ou des
chaussures voir des tour fait en
plastique un dimanche soit indispensable
ou revê un tel caractère d'urgence mais
l'autre point sur lequel je voulais
intervenir concerne les femmes salariées
concernées donc comment peuton imaginer
que que les femmes qui sont majoritaire
dans le secteur du commerce et dont une
part importante élève seul leurs enfants
seront en capacité de les faire garder
les dimanches cela a été développé par
Dominique vatrin alors que les crèches
les accueils les activités encadrées ne
fonctionnent pas elles devront faire
appel à un assistant ou une assistante
maternel dont la prise en charge pourra
selon le cas être prise en charge par
leur employeur encore faudra-t-il
trouver une personne disponible le
dimanche ou en soirée le ou la rémunérer
avec ce qu'elles auront gagné le
dimanche alors que rien n'assure le
niveau de compensation salariale est-ce
bien cela que l'on appelle sécuriser les
salariés ainsi donc en augmentant les
possibilités de déroger au principe du
repos dominical euh vous dérogez à un
principe fondamental pour lequel
pourtant nombre de vos collègues nombre
de parlementaires de votre famille
politique ici présent dans l'hémicycle
s'était engagé cela vient être rappelé
et il y a encore très peu de temps mais
aujourd'hui c'est l'économie qui prime
sur le social effectivement et les
consommateurs sur les salariés alors que
l'histoire a montré que ces deux notions
pouvait fort bien aller de paire ce
n'est pas notre vision de la société
c'est pourquoi nous proposons la
suppression de l'article 71 merci merci
Madame brick
oui les collègues qui se sont exprimés
notamment sur l'article 71 on fait
mention et c'est encore le cas dans
l'intervention de notre collègue bet
d'un d'une vision de la société
différente moi je crois qu'il est quand
même très excessif de parler d'un choix
de société d'un bouleversement de
civilisation non il faut raison garder
je crois que c'est un peu notre rôle ici
l'objectif de ce texte n'est pasobliger
tous les commerces à ouvrir les
dimanches tous les dimanches il n'est
pas non plus d'obliger les Français à
faire leurs
courses le dimanche la France ne va pas
se transformer en une vaste zone
commerciale donc je crois qu'il faut
lire le texte et euh bien regarder ce
qu'il dit alors cela étant c'est vrai
qu'en France le dimanche n'est pas un
jour
anodain c'est vrai euh le fait de
travailler le dimanche induit pour ceux
qui travaillent une organisation de leur
vie différente c'est vrai la vie
familiale amicale la vie sportive cultur
loisir et en quelque sorte différé alors
je pense que c'est un point d'attention
que nous allons avoir dans l'examen du
texte et augmenter le nombre potentiel
de personnes notamment de salariés qui
travailleront le dimanche n'est pas
anodin alors on doit effectivement
prendre prendre en compte dans la
législation de la situation des femmes
c'est vrai euh les les familles
monoparentales qui sont nombreuses du
reste dans les professions du commerce
et qui sont très souvent des femmes il
faut tenir compte des garanties du
volontariat du revenu
elles doivent être préservé ces
garanties c'est pourquoi il me semble
que tous les l'examen du texte qui va
nous mobiliser de jours et peut-être de
nuit c'est le principe qui me paraît
essentiel il a il y a deux principes
là-dedans le premier c'est le principe
pas d'accord pas d'ouverture il faut le
rappeler c'est fondamental le dialogue
social c'est un axe de du projet du
gouvernement par branche par entreprise
ou par territoire et nous sénateur on
est quand même le Conseil des
territoires nous savons que le
territoire n'est pas uniforme et je
crois que le deuxième principe c'est la
prise en compte du zonage alors après on
peut discuter comme toujours le zonage
ça comporte sa part d'arbitraire on peut
discuter effectivement mais on reconnaît
qu'il y a des zones touristiques
internationales et ça c'est très
important et qu'il y a des zones
commerciales on se situe quelque part
dans le le prolongement du texte maillé
il faut pas l'oublieré on ne légifère
pas comme ça d'un seul coup et il faut
faire aussi attention en fonction des
territoires à ne pas déséquilibrer les
formes de commerce qui existent et
notamment le petit commerce a été dit
alors il faut effectivement aussi être
attentif aux servicees publics parce que
effectivement ils pourront certains
pourront être amenés à fonctionner le
dimanche et on sait que ceux qui
travaillent le dimanche les agents
publics ont souvent des compensations
pécuniaères et des temps de repos
inférieurs à ce que les accords actuels
et à venir permettront d'obtenir donc il
peut y avoir aussi une pression de ses
salariés pour dire nous on veut comme
comme les salariés du privé mais ça
c'est la vie c'est la vie la loi elle ne
fixe pas tout après il y a la vie qui
décide donc je pense qu'en définitive
tout au long de c'est pour ça que je
suis évidemment au nom du groupe
socialiste contre la suppression parce
que je crois que ça vaut le coup de
discuter des compensations salariales je
crois que ça vaut le coup de discuter de
saesonnag je vois je crois que ça vaut
le coup de savoir qui décide avec qui et
c'est l'objet de nombreux amendements
entre la commune l'intercommunalité les
rôles de l'État qui est garant de
l'équilibre du territoire donc je crois
que ça vaut le coup d'en parler pendant
de jours et de nuit monsieur de
César bien pour dire que les écologistes
voteront l'amendement présenté par les
communistes parce que aujourd'hui il est
dit qu'il peut y avoir un dégr
dérogation accordé par le préfet pour un
temps limité là vous nous dites ça va
être 3 ans à plafond pour limiter les
abus alors on aurait été intéressé de
savoir quels sont les abus parce que
l'argument que vous nous avez donné
c'est c'est pour faire un inventaire que
le préfet va donner l'autorisation
d'ouvrir le dimanche un inventaire qui
dure 3 ans alors là c'est pour c'est
l'inventaire du siècle quoi parce que en
général un inventaire ça dure 15 jours 3
semaines mais de dire que ça dure 3 ans
l'inventaire alors là vraiment là on ne
comprend pas hein donc voilà pourquoi
nous associerons à cette amendement mais
madame madame brick vous posez le
problème de la philosophie vous
dites on n'est pas opposé à ce que le
dimanche garde un caractère spécial
spécifique bon ça a été d'ailleurs redit
par Madame linman que ça figure dans la
motion majoritaire du congrès socialiste
ce que n'est pas rien venez pas rien
hein j'ai cru l'entendre j'ai cru
l'entendre j'ai cru l'entendre mais
bon je poursuivez monsieur de cessard
chers collègues VO voilà voilà voilà non
revenons-en au texte c'est pas moi qui
discute j'ai j'ai entendu des choses
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
de cessar et à lui seul voilà bon mais
mais peut-être qu'encore je vais créer
certaines interrogations puisque j'ai
entendu le Premier ministre dire que le
1er mai ça a été le 1er mai où il y a eu
des acquis sociaux il y a eu un progrès
social donc là moi j'étais quand même
content j'ai dit bon voilà monsieur le
Premier ministre se situe encore dans la
conquête de droits sociaux dans le
progrès social il nous a dit ça le 1er
mai donc j'ai intéressé bon et donc
Madame brick d'accord c'est pas une
remise en cause partout du travail de
dimanche mais c'est une érosion des
droits c'est-à-dire que si vous ouvrez
le travail une catégorie supplémentaire
pour le travail de dimanche pourquoi pas
ouvrir des crèches pour ce jourl
puisquil y aura plus de gens qui vont
travailler pourquoi pas ouvrir d'autres
secteurs de l'économie c'est quelque
chose qui n'arrêtera pas et le problème
d'un principe c'est qu'on peut pas s'en
accommoder sans qui parfois et bien que
cela coûte et donc on peut réfléchir de
dire est-ce qu'on souhaite une société
où tous les jours sont pareils comme
est-ce qu'on souhaite à des territoire
où toutes les villes sont pareilles
c'est ce qui est en train de se produire
à l'échelle mondiale la standardisation
des villes ville vous allez dans les
villes vous retrouvez les mêmes magasins
partout que ça soit en Asie aux
États-Unis en France dans tous les pays
européens on trouve les mêmes boutiques
il y aura même plus plaisir à aller
aller visiter un autre pays et sauf pour
consommer bien sûr parce qu'on on va
comparer maintenant les prix entre pays
et pays voilà donc il y a une
standardisation est-ce qu'on souhaite
que le dimanche soit un jour comme les
autres non parce que c'est le jour des
échanges sociaux c'est le jour de
pratiqu communes c'est le jour où les
parents peuvent être avec leurs enfants
donc il faut le préserver si vous dites
on va gagner un peu plus d'argent parce
qu'on ouvre ici à Nice mais la ville
d'un côté Marseille va dire mais nous
aussi on a des touristes il faut ouvrir
et puis les villes d'à côté partout
maintenant vous développ tous les tous
les villages toutes les villes veulent
développer le tourisme donc tout le
monde va dire mais faut ouvrir pour nous
écoutez l' jour j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
qui est venu c'était pas ouvert le
dimanche mince il a pas pu consommer
donnez-moi une autorisation c'est
important pour la vie économique de mon
village vous allez aller dans cette
pente donc là vous êtes en train
d'ouvrir les barrières de lever les
barrières pour banaliser le dimanche
donc le dimanche effectivement parfois
on peut perdre un peu d'argent mais
c'est une société qu'on veut installer
un choix de société et comme je
reprendrai les termes du premier
ministre il faut continuer préserver les
acquis sociaux du premier ben merci
Madame David
oui merci monsieur le Président je je
vais rebondir sur ce que disait Jean de
cessard en effet monsieur le ministre
vous êtes vous défendez votre texte et
c'est normal et vous le défendez avec
passion et mais mais en réalité cet
article 71 néanmoins même s'il fixe une
durée de 3 ans Jean de cessard vient de
le dire il y avait déjà une durée de
fixée auparavant dans le en tout cas
c'était une durée limitée hein et ce qui
nous inquiète nous principalement c'est
que dans le code du travail précédemment
le chapitre dans lequel s'inscrivait le
titre dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
c'était dérogation temporaire accordé au
droit au travail dominical or là
maintenant vous transformez ce titre en
autre dérogation au repos dominical il
n'y a plus la notion de temporaire donc
voilà on peut s'interroger sur la durée
de 3 ans et sur le fait que vous ayez
supprimé le la notion de de temporaire
en plus euh ça a déjà été dit mais dans
dans le texte rien n'est dit sur comment
vont être renégociés et quelles sont les
les précisions sur les éléments
d'évaluations qui vont être prises en
compte pour
pouvoir redonner ou pas ces dérogations
d'une durée de 3 ans donc monsieur le
ministre vous nous dites pas tout à fait
vous nous enfin en tout cas nous nous
n'avons pas la même lecture que vous de
cette de cet article par ailleurs il est
dit aussi que s'il n'y a pas d'accord il
n'y aura pas d'ouverture le dimanche
mais enfin les accords vous savez très
bien que ça ce pourront être des des
accords locaux ce pourront être des
accords qui dérogent au droit qui est
aujourd'hui déjà minimaliste et qui est
inscrit dans le Code du travail et ce
pourront être aussi des accords qui se
feront de gréagré avec les salariés
puisqu'on pourra aller jusqu'à demander
au salariés lui-même s'il est d'accord
ou pas pour travailler le dimanche donc
en effet peut-être certains salariés
face à la situation actuelle de l'emploi
face au chômage qui me semble-t-il n'a
pas commencé encore sa pente descendante
mais bien au contraire continue
d'augmenter face à la pression aussi que
l'on peut mettre sur certains salariés
qui sont en situation de travail
temporaire et bien peut-être en effet
certaines et certains salariés
accepteront d'aller travailler le
dimanche mais on ne peut pas dans ces
cas-là parler de véritable volontariat
donc un accord un accord pourra être
effectivement trouvé mais quel genre
d'accord puisqu'il n'y a rien dans la
loi de contrepartie minimum légal et que
cet accord pourra être venir travailler
le dimanche avec par exemple 10 %
d'augmentation enfin 10 % de majoration
sur les heures travaillé et bien 10 % de
majoration sur les heures travaillées le
dimanche pour moi c'est inacceptable
c'est inacceptable car c'est toute une
société que nous sommes en train de
réécrire c'est c'est en fait la question
qu'il faut se poser dans ce texte c'est
quel projet de société voulons-nous pour
demain quelle société voulons-nous pour
nos pour nos jeunes est-ce que nos
étudiants par exemple qui seront la
cible privilégiée du travail du dimanche
est-ce que pour nos étudiants vous
pensez que c'est la bonne solution ou
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas comme
comme votre gouvernement d'ailleurs s'y
était engagé donner un statut à nos
étudiants pour leur permettre de se
consacrer à leurs études plutôt que
d'être obligé d'être des étudiants
salariés là ça aurait été une loi de
progrès social et une loi d'acquis qui
aurait pu emporter notre assentiment
mais pour le coup cet article 71 nous
n'en voulons pas et n nous ne retirerons
pas notre amendement de suppression
merci la parole est à Madame
yet alors on va le
mettre oui merci monsieur le Président
contre amendement
1666 donc cet amendement issu d'une
proposition de loi adoptée par le Sénat
en 2011 n'est pas différent dans ces
principes du présent projet de loi le
principe du zonage est acté de la même
façon puisque sont reprises les notions
de zone touristique et de périmètre
d'usage de consommation exceptionnel
autrement dit de zone commercial ah
excuse-moi
la parole est à monsieur Bouvard
oui monsieur le
Président merci alors on a parfois le
sentiment un peu de de s'imisser dans un
débat qui est qui est un débat
interne à la majorité et à l'approche
d'un d'un congrès certes important ceci
étant c'est un sujet qui mérite qu'on
s'y intéresse les uns et les autres et
et qui pose de véritables
interrogation c'est vrai que chacun a en
conscience
l'importance du repos dominical
l'importance de conforter la vie de
famille l'importance de maintenir des
liens sociaux de favoriser la vie
associative et il est vrai que si le
texte proposait purement et
simplement la suppression du du travail
du dimanche ce qui n'est pas le cas je
pense qu'il n'y
aurait très peu de parlementaires et
très peu de sénateurs bien évidemment
pour approuver une telle disposition en
l'occurrence pour ma part je le lis
comme un aménagement une
prolongation de dispositions qui ont été
adoptées durant les mandatures
précédentes par une autre majorité celle
à laquelle nous appartenons qui ont été
très critiqués à l'époque il faut s'en
souvenir
mais ces
dispositions s'avèrent néanmoins des
dispositions et des adaptations qui sont
aujourd'hui indispensable pas seulement
je veux dire pour pour générer de la
croissance ce qui est un point important
mais aussi parce que nous ne vivons pas
dans un univers fermé qu'il y a des
territoires qui sont des territoires
frontaliers qui regardent ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté de la
frontière
j'étais il y a une
semaine pour un déplacement et
professionnel et familial à Turin dans
une grande ville industrielle qui est en
même temps une grande cité touristique
et l'ensemble des commerce était ouvert
le dimanche et Turin est une ville moins
touristique sans doute que ne l'est
Paris sans doute que le nénis et donc et
et donc cette évolution C évolution nous
devons la prendre en compte alors certes
il y a dans cet article un certain
nombre de de dispositions qui mériteront
d'ailleurs discussion je pense au
majorations de rémunération obligatoire
puisque il y a sur une partie de notre
territoire des zones touristiques des
stations de tourisme où l'ensemble des
activités fonctionneent pendant toute
une saison d'hiver et où le caractère
saisonnier de l'activité fait que les
rémunérations prennent déjà en compte
cet aspect des choses ce que le texte
d'ailleurs dans sa version initiale a
oublié et donc il conviendra qu'on y
apporte les adaptations nécessaires mais
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse purement et
simplement considérer qu'il n'y a pas
lieu à débattre que l'article n'a pas
d'utilité qu'on peut rester sur une
situation figée sans ne rien changer et
sans faire comme si un certain nombre de
jurisprudence
qui ont été établis depuis le vote de la
loi mier qui ont abouti aux surprises et
aux incohérences que chacun a constaté
ne devait pas être corrigé par le
législateur et je crois que c'est parce
que ce débat est nécessaire parce que
nous devons l'avoir en responsabilité
parce que nous devons l'avir avec les
équilibres qu'il convient d'apporter
entre le repos dominical et la nécessité
économique et la réalité des activités
touristiques notamment que nous devons
pouvoir discuter de cet
article de manière
sereine et de manière réaliste merci
Monsieur monsieur le ministre vous
m'avez demandé la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président non je
souhaitais comme le débat va être long
et compliqué sur ce sujet qu'on ait
chacune et chacun ensemble l'esprit de
rigueur sur ce dont nous parlons
l'article 71 de quoi s'agit-il je vais
pas ici lancer le débat nous l'aurons
sur les jours du ma les zones
touristiques et autres il s'agit de
venir préciser ce qui est au l31 32- 20
de l'actuel code je lis l'article pour
que ce soit clair pour tout le monde
lorsqu'il est établi que le repos
simultané le dimanche de tous les
salariés d'un établissement serait
préjudiciable au public ou
compromettrait le fonctionnement normal
de cet établissement le repos peut-être
autorisé par le préfet soit toute
l'année soit à certaines époques de
l'année seulement suivant l'une des
modalités suivantes un autre jour que le
dimanche à tous les salariés de
l'établissement du dimanche midi au
lundi midi le dimanche après-midi avec
un repos compensateur d'une journée par
roulement et par quinzaine et par
roulement à toute ou partie des salariés
voilà le droit existant nous venons
préciser à cela le fait que les
autorisations prévues à cet article sont
accordé pour une durée qui ne peut
excéder 3 ans et donc je vous rassure il
ne s'agit pas que de l'exemple que je
donnais tout à l'heure à à savoir de
revoir un dépôt ou autre il peut savoir
il peut s'agir d'une autorisation
préfectorale qui est donnée pour une
partie de l'année comme comme le texte
du L300 du L pardon 31 32- 200 le dit ou
pour toute l'année pour un commerce donc
c'est le droit actuel nous nous venons
dire ces dérogations qui sont données
par le préfet dans le droit actuel et
bien faut pas que ça ça dure plus de 3
ans parce qu'il faut tous les 3 ans
revoir la situation et voir si c'est
encore valide donc c'est ça qu'on vient
apporter j'ajoute à ce point mais les
textes il faut les lire ensemble sinon
on parle de de choses qui sont qui sont
vagues donc les autorisations prévue à
l'article l31 32- 20 sont accordés pour
une durée qui ne peut exercer 3 ans et
on introduit des avis qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dans le 31 32- 200 et donc
on a on met l'avis du conseil municipal
le cas échéant de le PCI à fiscalité
propre des Chambre de Commerce et des
métiers et cetera donc ces avis sont
donnés en plus de l'existant on les
rajoute et le deuxième parag qui me
permet de répondre à monsieur le
sénateur boet en cas d'urgence du
justifié et lorsque le nombre de
dimanches pour lesquels l'autorisation
prévue à l'article L 31 32- 200 n'excède
pas 3 les avis préalables mentionnés au
premi alinéa du présent article ne sont
pas requis le cas d'urgence ne vaut que
pour les avis que nous venons rajouter
mais il ne change rien à l'existant il
n'enlève rien dans l'existant et donc
l'urgence dont nous parlons de quoi
s'agit-il de manière très simple vous
avez un droit actuel qui permet des
autorisations préfectorales nous nous
disons ces autorisations préfectorales
il faut les encadrer de deux façons
créer des avis préalables qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui et est limité dans le
temps à 3 ans et ce qu'on dit simplement
quand il y a une urgence dûement
justifié dûement justifié typiquement
les cas que j'aiévoqué tout à l'heure et
bien on peut si c'est justifié déroger
aux avis que nous venons créer donc
c'est simple si vous supprimez cet
article vous restez au droit actuel
c'est-à-dire que les avis préfectoraux
ne feront l'objet d'absolument aucun
avis ni des conseil municipaux et autres
puisque c'est le droit actuel et ne
seront pas limités dans le temps et donc
pardon de vous le dire mais c'est un tin
incohérent avec l'ensemble de
l'argumentation qui est la vôtre sur ces
sujets je me permettais simplement
d'attirer votre attention là-dessus si
nous voulons discuter de textes qui sont
compliqué parce que l'état du droit est
compliqué il faut les articuler les uns
avec les autres et donc je vous dis
simplement que aujourd'hui nous venons
rajouter nous venons rajouter des
éléments qui sont en supplément du 31
32- 20 et nous les ajoutons dans cet
état
d'esprit merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur
Colomba alors il est où je voudrais
intervenir disons d'une façon un petit
peu un petit peu globale et parce que
pardelà donc les les les problèmes
techniques c'est-à-dire la question et
la question du degré de grignotage du
repos dominical auquel ce texte nous
convie après d'autres puis avant
d'autres parce que la modernisation est
en marche autant continuer ou non bien
sûr de l'amélioration de la
compétitivité je voudrais attirer votre
attention chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
sur deux sujets d'étonnement et qui font
qui font que je voterai cette cet
amendement le premier c'est que vous le
savez comme moi c'est que depuis déjà
quelques siècles et surtout depuis 50
ans la la productivité du travail a
littéralement explosé il s'en est suivi
pendant pas mal d'années une diminution
du temps de travail des salariés or
depuis quelques temps on assiste au
mouvement
inverse
donc plus le travail est productif plus
on doit travailler je trouve ça quand
même assez
paradoxal je trouve ça assez paradoxal
et je trouve le système qui nous conduit
à cela assez étrange on s'est posé la
question depuis longtemps je me rappelle
par exemple on trouve dans Aristote nous
dit déjà quand il discutait de l'esclav
disait quand les métiers tisseront tout
seul et quand les plectes sonont tout
seul et bien il n'y aura plus
d'esclavage là les plectres c'estàd
les les les lires ou les les clavins ou
les peuvent jouer tout seul vous mettez
votre
disque et puis on continue quand même à
travailler un peu plus et quand au mtier
à tiser je vous fais pas je ne vous fais
pas de dessins donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'un peu paradoxal et je
crois que à se perdre trop dans les
détails techniques on finit par oublier
ce que peut avoir d'un peu in congru
cette évolution de notre société le
deuxème le deuxème point sur lequel je
voudrais attirer votre attention c'est
le présupposé selon lequel il suffit de
produire pour avoir des
débouchés même je reprendrai ce que ce
qu'a développé toute mon collègue de
cessar je veux dire même les touristes
ils ont un budget limité donc ce qu'ils
peuvent pas dépenser un jour bah ils le
dépenseront le lendemain d'autant que la
plupart de ces touristes ils sont
tellement bien encadrés que on sait où
les mener aux bons endroits pour pouvoir
les rançonner en toute
honnêteté donc voilà voilà où on en est
alors je sais bien que c'est un peu un
lundi matin faire un peu de de
métaphysique ou se poser des questions
aussi vaseuses que celles que je viens
de poser ça peut paraître un peu
incongru
mais quand même qu'est-ce qu'on est en
train de fabriquer qu'est-ce qu'on est
en train de fabriquer comme
société
question vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues euh j'écoute
avec attention et j'ai également
regarder euh ce qu'était les réflexions
émises par la rapporteur de la mission
euh on est sur des autorisations qui
sont normalement de type dérogatoire or
une dérogation qui dure 3 ans pour des
situations particulières exceptionnelles
puisque c'est c'est ça l'idée c'est
quand même un peu particulier je pense
qu'un inventaire que chaque année pour
faire son inventaire un commerce demande
une autorisation n'est pas n'est pas
quelque chose de de difficile et je
pense qu'à partir du moment où c'est un
inventaire je vois pas pourquoi il
faudrait donner 3 ans de toute façon il
y a pas de motivation à ce qu'il y ait
une durée par rapport à cet aspect là
donc j'avoue que je ne comprends pas
bien la motivation déjà par par rapport
à cela mais j'ai regardé attentivement
madame la rapporteur nous dit que selon
les informations qui lui ont été
communiquées pour Paris
euh sur la très grande majorité des
ouvertures
ponctuelles celles-ci peuvent apporter
une solution difficultés rencontrée par
des commerces qui voisins d'une zone
dérogatoire au repos
dominical subissent un préjudice en
raison de la concurrence des commerces
qui sont ouverts le dimanche je crois
qu'on on est là donc dans une situation
qui montre bien que l'ouverture des
dimanches est une situation qui
fragilise les activités commerciales
installées dans les zones proches des
secteurs qui qui sont ouverts le
dimanche et que en voulant donner la
capacité de faire des régimes
dérogatoir sur 3 ans on est en train
probablement d'étendre les zones de
demande dérogatoire qui seront sollicité
par ceux qui seront à proximité de ces
zones touristiques particulières pour
être maire d'une commune et donc être
amené à être sollicité chaque année par
par les commerçants sur les ouvertures
du dimanche il a fallu qu'on s'organise
dans notre intercommunalité de telle
façon à ce que les mêmes enseignes
n'ouvrent pas sur des sur des communes
différentes et pour
accumuler le nombre d'ouverture pour la
même enseigne donc on voit bien que le
contournement de la loi est est
permanent et je ne suis pas sûr que
simplement une demande
d'avis soit suffisamment contraignante
pour qu'elle limite comme vous le dites
la proposition qui nous est faite c'est
pourquoi
je pense que notre amendement est
totalement justifié merci Monsieur
gabouti
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues personnellement
je ne suis pas particulièrement attaché
au repos dominical mais plutôt dans une
optique laïque auou repos
hebdomadaire parce que la logique veut
que non mais
voilà donc je je me permets cette
réflexion qui est on part quand même de
de de cette de cette notion alors
euh faut-il que faut-il que ce jour soit
dans la mesure du possible le même pour
tous la réponse bien entendu est oui
pour des raisons familiales des raisons
des raisons
sociales ou des raisons religieuses
puisqu'on doit tenir compte aussi je je
fais un monde honorable si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi
euh je dirais on doit on doit tenir
compte également de notre culture de
notre histoire y compris sur le plan euh
je dirais des des convictions et de de
je dirais de notre histoire religieuse
donc adoptons effectivement le dimanche
comme jour de repos en en faisant quand
même remarquer que si je regarde
l'ensemble de ces activités activité
familial activité amicale activité
sportive activité culturelle activité
associatives elle se pratique
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus à partir du
samedi midi
que le dimanche après-midi c'est c'est
un constat ce n'est pas je dirais le
dimanche après-midi étant plutôt
consacré au repos alors que tout ce qui
est animation et sociétale se déroule
plutôt effectivement le samedi et le
samedi soir dimanche soir il y a pas de
match de foot ni de rugby il sont ils
sont je suis désolé il sont ils sont
plutôt le samedi c'est rare c'est rare
c'est rare en tout cas en tout cas oui
non mais il y en a exceptionnellement
pour des raisons de des raisons de
retransmis des raisons mercant madame
BRI de retransmission
télévisée voilà alors que les jeunes je
dirais en éducation en éducation au
niveau au niveau des clubs en éducation
au niveau des clubs ça se fait beaucoup
plus effectivement le le le
samedi donc on on moi je pose la
question je je je je je ne tranche pas
en même temps il faut penser que si j'ai
lu certains sondages alors qu' valent ce
qu' valent comme tous les sondages
qu'effectivement 70 % des Français
souhaitent pouvoir acheter et pouvoir
faire leurs cours et sont favorables à
l'ouverture le dimanche mais que 70 %
des Français ou des salariés ne
souhaitent pas travailler le dimanche
donc voilà donc ça c'est la
contradiction un petit peu de notre je
dirais de notre société qu'il faut
essayer de qu'il faut essayer de gérer
donc personnellement je je seraiis et
puis notre groupe à cette attitude
disons à la fois pragmatique c'est de
conserver effectivement ce jour de repos
hebdomadaire qui est le dimanche
euh d'assouplir partout il y a
possibilité d'augmenter l'activité
économique et non pas de la transférer
hein je crois qu'il y a une différence
entre l'augmentation de l'activité
économique et le transfert si c'est pour
faire la même activité en étalant les
achat sur le dimanche au lieu du reste
de la semaine ça ne présente pas
beaucoup d'intérêt doncou tout à fait
pour les zones touristiques c'est tout à
fait c'est tout à fait le cas donc là où
il y a possibilité d'augmenter
l'activité économique et donc
effectivement
d'avoir ces activités qui sont
créattives emploi il faut apporter le
maximum de souplesse et ailleurs je
dirais simplement des facilités comme
nous avons actuellement sur les périodes
de Noël où effectivement ça facilite
tout le monde d'avoir des ouvertures un
petit peu je dirais en dehors de la
semaine pour y compris d'ailleurs pour
les pour les salariés eux-mêmes donc cet
assouplissement avec aussi je demande
d'être attentif là-dessus moi je
présenterai des amendements sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui lorsque vous d'aller dans
des zones commerciales ou des zones qui
ne sont pas définies comme des zones
commerciales simplement des magasins ou
passer dans les villes dans les zones
industrielles aujourd'hui la loi n'est
pas respectée c'est-à-dire que on ne
fait pas respecter la loi alors nous
sommes plutôt pour l'assouplissement
mais pour un respect strict de la loi
c'est-à-dire que là où il n'y a pas lieu
d'ouvrir le dimanche il faut pas que les
magasins ouvrent le dimanche alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très largement
ouvert avec des des pratiques qui
contournent totalement la voie la loi
sans être sanctionné c'est C équilibre
qu'il faut
effectivement rechercher c'est-à-dire
une loi assouplie facilitant les choses
gardant le principe je dirais du repos
d'un jour qui est le repos dominical
mais en même temps faire respecter la
loi merci Monsieur gabouti Madame Gillot
vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je voudrais intervenir au
nom de salariés qui travaillent dans ces
conditions depuis déjà plus de 20 ans
alors j'ai entendu parler de d'érosion
de droit it de grignotage de droit moi
aujourd'hui dans le débat actuel j'ai
plutôt l'impression qu'il s'agit de
confirmer de préciser des droits acquis
difficilement et auquel tiennent des
salariés notamment situés en zone de
puce dans mon territoire alors l'arrêté
du préfet va expirer au mois de juin et
je peux vous dire que tous les mois le
responsable du centre commercial me
sollicite pour être sûr que la
dérogation sera bien reconduite le temps
de l'application de la mise en
application de de la loi dite Macron il
y a une grande inquiétude aujourd'hui
chez les
salariés qui craignent de revenir à ce
qui s'est passé il y a 6 ans il y a 6
ans les magasins qui ouvraient le
dimanche depuis 20 ans euh parce que
c'est un centre commercial qui ouvre 7
jours sur 7 de 10h à 20h avec une
organisation d'encouragement au travail
du dimanche qui était très bien perçu et
qui était très sollicité dans cette
partie de notre territoire
d'île-de-fance et bien euh les magasins
étaient régulièrement menacés de
fermeture par des contentieux engagés
par un un syndicat qui trouvait là
l'occasion l'opportunité de pardon
l'opportunité de d'obtenir des des
compensation les menaces d'astreines
financière journalière préjudiciable au
maintien de l'activité économique ont
failli avoir raison de cette belle
expérience économique alors je comprends
la surprise de certains autour de cette
dans cette salle puisque j'ai déjà eu à
l'affronter il y a 6 ans au moment de la
l'élaboration de la loi maillet dans
laquelle je me suis impliquée pour
défendre effectivement les droits des
salariés du centre commercial art de
vivre à
iragny alors je témoigne d'une
expérience durable qui rayonne et qui
permet à des familles de travailler
comme elle le souhaite sans aucune
contrainte et je le dis clairement
puisque je le vérifie moi-même même j'ai
été maire jusqu'en
2014 tous les ans j'avais sur mon bureau
les cont les contrats les la charte de
fonctionnement de ce centre commercial
qui garantissait le volontariat du
travail du dimanche pour les contrats
pour les salariés en contrat à durée
permanente ou à durée temporaire qui
garantissait la valorisation de leur
salairire et qui garantissait que il n'y
avait aucune contrainte dans leur
manière de faire alors cette bien sûr
c'est la loi et ce qui est proposé mais
ce qui est proposé madame c'est que
aujourd'hui cette dérogation elle soit
ramenée à 3 ans dans les dans les zones
de puce c'est 5 ans et le décret du
préfet qui va expirer là il datait de 5
ans je vous assure que les salariés
aujourd'hui sont très attentifs à ce que
nous disons mais moi je connais très
bien aussi et je pense qu'on peut
s'exprimer librement sans terrorisme
l'ensemble des chefs d'entreprise sont
très attachés à ces formes qui
témoignent de leurs bonnes pratiques et
même ils sont amenés je tiens à le dire
à organiser une espèce de turnover pour
le dimanche notamment pour les salariés
à à temps complet parce que le travail
le dimanche est mieux rémunéré et qu'il
y aurait une un groupe d'habitués qui
fagociterait ce travail du dimanche
alors qu'il est très apprécié notamment
par les familles monoparentales qui ont
été évoqué tout à l'heure parce que
quand il y
a difficulté de faire garder les enfants
bah le weekend où c'est le deuxième
parent qui garde les enfants et bien
celui qui travaille le dimanche est
libre de ça il y a aussi les
grands-parents il y a aussi des familles
non enfin des couples qui élèvent leurs
enfants leurs enfants qui s'organisent
pour travailler chacun leur tour de
manière à améliorer leurs revenus et ça
n'est pas du tout un substitut une à la
précarité c'est une liberté pour les
gens g de travailler et de faire
d'améliorer leurs conditions de travail
je j'ajoute que c'est une zone j'ajoute
que c'est une une un secteur
universitaire où de nombreux étudiants
salariés travaillent 2 jours par semaine
pour financer leurs études et c'est tout
à fait ça participe de leur expérience
ça participe de la valorisation de leur
de leur expérience
professionnelle ultérieure et je peux
vous assurer que ici à IRAG à sergit
Pontoise ce qui se passe dans cet
hémicycle est très observé parce que il
y a des salariés qui tiennent beaucoup à
leur liberté de travailler le
dimanche madame
linman n RA je comprends bien que ma
collègue qui a un centre commercial
chers collègues je vous invite au
silence et à laisser les orateurs
s'exprimer je comprends vous avez la
parole je comprends bien bien les
arguments donnés par ma collègue qui est
élu d'un secteur où il y a un centre
commercial qui est ouvert nonstop mais
il se trouve que j'ai été oui enfin oui
c'est ça et donc et le dimanche et
cetera mais il se trouve que j'ai été
moi-même élu d'une commune où il y avait
des centres commerciaux de cette nature
ouverts au voisinage et que demandaient
les commerces les grandes surfaces les
commerces voisins c'est d'avoir les
mêmes ouvertures car pourquoi la
clientèle captive d'un secteur irait
vers le grand centre commercial voisin
plutôt que d'aller sur les moyens
centres commerciaux existant ou sur les
commerces de proximité et cette logique
comme nous sommes dans un un système de
concurrence cette logique elle induit
une demande qui élargit en permanence
cette ce secteur pour quel bilan parce
que le bilan a été fait de l'ouverture
de certains secteurs le dimanche
c'est que pour une large part ce n'est
pas rentable c'est une perte sèche pour
certains qui même s'ils ouvrent le
dimanche ne récupéreront pas parce que
les frais fixes d'ouverture plus les
frais salariés ne rentabilise pas
leur je te parle de ceux qui ne sont pas
ton centre commercial ça a été ça existé
je l'ai vu dans la commune dont j'ai été
élu et donc nous avons observé
d'ailleurs toute une série de de patrons
de grande surface vous le disent si
c'est ouvert nulle part nous n'avons
aucun nous n'avons pas de problème c'est
à partir du moment où c'est ouvert
quelque part que tout le monde a besoin
de pouvoir concurrencer entre guillemets
à armes égales donc moi personnellement
je pense que c'est à haut risque quand à
l'argumentaire bien compris bien connu
les salariés sont libres ils ne sont que
volontaires il y a des chartes de bonnes
pratique évidemment quand vous avez des
millions de chômeurs quand vous avez le
choix entre ça et ne pas avoir quelque
chose à la fin du mois c'est quoi votre
liberté c'est attendez c'est quoi votre
liberté à la limite à la limite si ça
crée des nouveaux emplois et que ce ne
soit pas de nature à déstabiliser
d'autres emplois si c'était une vraie
extension de l'activité réelle ça se
discute et on parle des contreparties